[تصفيق]
حرب دبابات طرحها الوضع الحالي في
اوكرانيا تستعرض فيها اطراف القتال
والاطراف الدوليه قدرتها العسكريه وتراهن
بها على المكاسب على الارض الجيش الروسي
ثاني اقوى جيوش العالم حسب مؤشر القوه
العسكريه ورثه معظمه رسانته من الدبابات
من الاتحاد السوفيتي لتصل ترسانته من
الدبابات القتاليه الاساسيه فقط الى نحو
ثلاثه الاف و800 دبابه في الخدمه واحد
10,400 دبابه احتياطيه
تشارك الانواع الابرز منها في الحرب على
اوكرانيا
جي 7 2 دخلت الخدمه عام
1973 المدفع الرئيسي 125 ملم املس
[موسيقى]
قوات المحرك 780 حصان السرعه القصوى
للطريق 60 كم في الساعه المدى 500 كلم
تي اي تي دخلت الخدمه عام
متر املس محرك
قوه المحرك الف حصان السرعه القصوى للطريق
70 كم في الساعه المدى
335 كلم
الخدمه عام
1993 المدفع الرئيسي 125 ملم املس يحرك
ديزل قوه المحرك 840 حصان السرعه القصوى
للطريق 60 كم في الساعه المدى 550 كلم
الا انا احدث الدبابات الروسيه وفخر
الصناعتها هي ارماتا التي لم تدخل الخدمه
بعد وتزعم موسكو انها تتفوق على دبابه
ابرامز الامريكيه كونها تندمج بشكل اكبر
ضمن شبكه معلومات واحده تربط مختلفه
الاسلحه كما ان طاقمها يكون محمدا داخل
كبسوله مدرعه منفصله عن حموله الذخيره الى
عمر العربيه